(upbeat music)
- This is the only place in San Francisco
you can see bison.
This is the best spot to
view the Golden Gate Bridge.
This is one of the oldest
gay bars in the city, cheers.
But it all starts here,
at the concierge desk
of the Fairmont, San Francisco.
(upbeat music)
I'm Tom Wolfe, and I'm
America's first concierge.
I was very lucky because
my parents loved to go out,
so I was constantly seeing
the world of hospitality,
the world of new restaurants,
the world of sophistication,
and that's kind of where
the seed was planted,
shall we say.
My first hotel job was
working in Washington D.C.,
and I then went to London,
and the general manager
asked me, "Have you got a morning suit?"
Luckily, I knew what a morning suit was,
and I said, “Of course, Mr. Schwinter, I do.”
My next port of call would be Paris.
I managed to get a job
at a very luxurious hotel
right on the Champs-Elysées,
and I learned many lessons.
I made my way back to the United States,
where I found myself in San Francisco.
I started as the concierge
at the Fairmont in 1974.
The Fairmont Hotel occupies
an entire square block.
The main building opened in
1907, one year to the day
after the great fire.
If these walls could whisper,
what stories they would tell.
A secret door, that could
be used for a discreet exit.
The Tonga Room was once
The Fairmont swimming pool.
If you can think of somebody
important, they were here.
Whether they were from
the world of Hollywood,
or the world of politics.
Pretty much every president
has stayed here at one time
or another.
And we had the first person
to break the color barrier
in the Venetian Room, where
an entertainer of color
would be able to stay at the same place
where they performed.
The Fairmont philosophy has always been,
the best kind of guest you can
hope for is a repeat guest.
(light music)
When I'm out and about
walking to this very day,
I'm still exploring.
And I find these little streets
that I haven't been down,
or I find a shop that I've not been in,
and I take the time to go in,
say hello and introduce myself.
It's a constant learning experience.
And the minute you stop
learning, well, you might as well
stop working.
(light music)